Rob Kardashian and blac Chyna's  relationship continues to be a colorful  I fell in love with you because I know  how good you are how loyal you are the  new mom shared this cryptic Instagram  late Thursday I have some things I want  to get off my chest about how I truly  feel about Rob I wouldn't regret  anything China never followed up with  those things though in less than 24  hours earlier she Rob were making out on  snapchat the couple's reality show is  back Sunday night for a special all  about baby dreams birth and China gets  emotional in this new sneak peak minute  wernicki a look at how she got your man  ex for my baby to be healthy have all  their toes you having a brief on her own  don't worry this whole home look how  pretty looks all right  where girl  woody  [Music]